entschuldigen sie dass wir so radikal
eben hier aus der maz rausgegangen sind
und hier wieder einen deutschen
bundestag zurück gekehrt sind aber nach
diesem abstimmungsmarathon wollten wir
doch die letzte abstimmung wenigstens
auch noch live für sie treffen
686 abgeordnete sind dann doch noch
hiergeblieben für die letzte abstimmung
namentlicher art hier 79 haben für den
afg antrag gestimmt ich muss gerade auf
die hat 82 abgeordnete also sehr
diszipliniert aber wie zu erwarten war
natürlich keiner darüber hinaus 607 mit
nein gestimmt und wenn man einen strich
unter den heutigen vormittag man muss
schon sagen mittag macht dann kann man
sagen das ist schon überraschend hier
gelaufen zumindest in der entwicklung
dass zum einen hier der gesetzentwurf
gleich am anfang abgestimmt wurde nicht
so wie das die ampel fraktionen wollten
am ende das war schon ein wenig
überraschend und die zweite überraschung
dann dann doch die klare abfuhr für alle
vier anträge
alle vier anträge haben hier keine
mehrheit bekommen insofern ändert sich
am status quo in deutschland im moment
nichts hans werner ja das ist eine
interessante anmerkung gehört der status
quo in deutschland ich würde ganz gerne
bevor wir weiter sprechen mal die zahl
nochmal nennen also
328 menschen sind innerhalb der letzten
24 stunden gestorben an corona mehr als
200 1000 neue infektionen werden
gemeldet das heißt dieses furchtbar hohe
niveau der menschen die sterben immer
mehr als 300 hält sich weiterhin so viel
sozusagen zum pandemischen hintergrund
dieser debatte heute das war ja durchaus
spannend die ganze zeit ist hat ja
mehrere stunden gedauert du hast ja
gesagt heute morgen die aussprache hat
ja viel länger gedauert als geplant
jetzt unterm strich gibt es keine
impfpflicht in deutschland auf absehbare
zeit gehört kann man jetzt sagen dass
damit sozusagen alle irgendwie verloren
haben sowohl die ampel und ihre fraktion
als auch die union oder wie ist das zu
interpretieren
ja es ging ja zunächst nicht um die
ampel oder die union sondern der
bundeskanzler hatte diese abstimmung ja
in das parlament hinein gereicht einer
notlösung von olaf scholz weil er in der
ampel keine mehrheit hat für eine
impfpflicht das liegt an der fdp
natürlich und das ist ja auch ein
legitimes anliegen vieler liberaler dass
sie sagen das geht zu weit aber da waren
nun der kanzler in einer misslichen
situation hat das in den bundestag
gegeben es waren dann gruppenanträge
aber das vermischte sich heute so ein
bisschen natürlich weil nämlich der
gesetzentwurf der ja letzten endes dann
ein kompromiss darstellt also eine
helmpflicht ab 60 sei ab dem herbst das
waren nur abgeordnete der ampel die das
unterstützt haben und deswegen war das
hier so ein mischmasch heute beide
seiten sowohl die ampel die ja diese
abstimmung quasi verloren hat was den
ablauf hier angeht wie aber auch die
union die natürlich mit dem
ungewöhnlichen brief der
fraktionsführung an die einzelnen
abgeordneten hier schon gezeigt hat dass
es ihr nicht nur um die sache geht
sondern auch darum dass eben hier der
antrag den der kanzler unterstützte das
eine impfpflicht eben keine mehrheit
bekommen zumindest nicht eine
impfpflicht die von den ampel fraktionen
hier diktiert wurde das ist schon
natürlich bei beiden seiten so dass man
sagen kann hier gibt es keinen klaren
sieger und du hast ja die zahlen noch
mal genannt umso erstaunlicher ist dass
viele der meinung sind dass man auch
masken und alles andere jetzt loswerden
kann jetzt kommt der sommer dass es
richtig und das ist das ärgerliche im
herbst stehen wir vielleicht vor dem
dritten herbst wo die politiker wieder
zusammenkommen werden in
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen die
übrigens ja heute auch noch stattfindet
aber eher zum thema ukraine dann kommen
sie wieder zusammen und dann wird wieder
gerätselt wie sollen wir es denn machen
über 300 tote am tag das ist ein
flugzeugabsturz das hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister vor einiger
zeit ja mal gesagt und man hat sich
schon fast an diese zahlen gewöhnen
zumal immer wieder beschworen wird das
omikron ja gar nicht so ansteckend ist
aber
dann fragt man sich schon warum diese
riesen zahlen wir sind in den letzten
zwei jahren alle zu mehr oder minder
experten geworden und müssen am heutigen
tag bekennen so richtig wissen wir auch
nicht was der richtige weg gewesen wäre
der gesetzgeber die parlamentarier im
deutschen bundestag jedenfalls haben
keine entscheidung getroffen sie wissen
es halt auch nicht